hello and welcome to biographics I'm
your interim and slightly less
aerodynamic host Carl Smallwood and
today we're talking about Bob Marley The
Legend Of Music written by Radu
Alexander
one good thing about music is that when
it hits you you don't feel pain those
are the immortal words of the legendary
Bob Marley a man who thought that music
could bring the world together in peace
and unity and even if you're not a fan
of Bob Marley or his music chances are
you like at least one of his songs
Marley took a new and Innovative sound
that was largely relegated to be dance
halls and Airways of Jamaica and turn
them into something that was not just
International but Timeless
[Music]
Bob Marley was born Robert nasta Mali on
February 6 1945 in his maternal
grandfather's Farm in Nine Mile a
district of Saint and Parish in Jamaica
which was still a British colony at the
time anyway his mother was sadella
Malcolm a local girl was now 18 when she
became pregnant with Bob his father a
much more enigmatic figure in the area
of Jamaica and it was called norvel
Sinclair Marley and was almost 60 years
old when he met Bob Marley's mum
everybody just called Norville Captain
though it's unclear whether or not it's
just a nickname game or if he actually
served in any sort of military or Naval
capacity and if it wasn't already clear
from the name Norville Captain was white
something Bob Marley grew to his end in
his later years due to teasing he
received from other boys shortly after
sedala gave birth to Bob from that point
our novel became something of a familial
it's the Muriel presence in his son's
life till he died 10 years later at age
70 when Bob was only 10 years old as an
adult Marley didn't have any nice things
to say about his father in fact he
barely acknowledged existence at all and
kept a single Memento of his father's
existence an old photograph of a white
man riding a horse during his childhood
Bob moved around for a bit until 1957
when he and his mother moved from the
slums of Kingston into the government
yard of trenchtown where and I quote
Georgie would make fire lights and they
would cook cornmeal porridge
sounds really nice cornmeal party sounds
super nice I'll have to get me some
cornmeal porridge after this their
sadella Marley made the acquaintance of
a carpenter named Thaddeus Livingston
who already had eight children including
a boy about Bob's age named Neville
although everyone simply called him
Bonnie yeah okay Bonnie's a much better
name pretty quickly Bob and Bunny became
thick as thieves and would while away
many an evening singing and playing on a
homemade guitar like Bonnie made from an
old Sardine Can some bamboo for the neck
and insulation copper wiring for the
strings he wasn't exactly a Stratocaster
but it got the job done the late 50s
early 60s were a quintessential time for
Jamaica's music scene as local artists
were busy exploring and defining the
genres that would go on to become
popular the entire world over scar
Rocksteady and of course the reggae one
of the artists was Joe Hicks part of
excessive duo called modeling off Higgs
and Wilson and he lived in trench town
and his house was often turned to a
naval dancehall where local would-be
musicians turned up to show their stuff
as well as study under higgs's Learning
Tree while attending one of these
open-air music sessions Bob and Bonnie
made the acquaintance of another Young
artist who's name was Winston Hubert
McIntosh although he went by Peter Tosh
for obvious reasons immediately he
grabbed Miley's attention because he
possessed a rare artifact among the poor
musicians of trenchtown an actual guitar
that had not been improvised from scrap
pass and sardine guns the three quickly
struck up a fast friendship where they
discovered their singing harmonized
pretty well together and decided to make
some beautiful music many others will
join them at various points during their
career but the core Trio consisted of
Mali Bunning and Tosh all they needed
now was a name and at first they went by
the teenagers because you know they were
they were teenagers which they didn't
quite like so they changed that to the
Wailing rude boys which they also didn't
like changing it again to the Wailing
Whalers and then finally and more simply
The Wailers
foreign
it was fairly obvious that Bob Marley
was the breakout starter group Joe Higgs
are taking the teenage musician under
his wing was impressed with Miley's
dedication towards improvising and
improving upon his craft in 1962 Bob
Marley met with a Jamaican record who's
called Leslie Kong most of dazzling by
performing on the spot in the middle of
his shop without accompaniment Khan
agreed to produce Marley's first single
a song titled judge not he received
almost no airtime and made the singer
peanuts but still he'd released his
first record of a tender age of 16. he
ended up recording two more songs later
that year one cup of coffee and Terror
again neither of which set the charts on
fire but didn't exactly discourage him
from making more music as you've
probably already surmised I didn't know
one of his songs got a cup of coffee I
was just very thirsty still if the soul
light wasn't working out maybe people
would have had more success with the
Whalers the following year Mali met
another of the leading likes of
Jamaica's music scene record producer
Clement coxown dot where Higgs taught
young Bob to embrace his passion for
music Hicks taught him to
see what the music industry was really
about and how it worked he also saw
promise in the whaler so in 1963 he
helped produce their first single simmer
down unlike Miley's previous solo
efforts this was a hit at least in
Jamaica and in 1964 he reached the top
of the charts in that country two more
hits followed it hurts to be alone and
Lonesome feeling but just because the
group was getting popular it did not
exactly translate into any sort of
financial Bonanza quite the opposite in
fact because for the first few years
Mali had been homeless his mother had
married a man named Edward Booker and
moved to America specifically Wilmington
Delaware I am in Delaware hi
I'm old without his mother Marley
couldn't afford a place to sleep so he
spent most nights sleeping in Dodgers
record Studio
using an old door propped on cinder
blocks this is one of the most legendary
well-known famous vicinity slots on the
door
why a doll unfortunately even back then
the music industry was as predatory as
ever and producers like Dodd kept most
of the earnings since they provided the
studio and the equipment while musicians
and we received a pittance because it's
not like they were doing anything right
just creating all the music that people
like to listen to I sure am glad we're
past that since there was always more
Starving Artists out there to exploit
eventually Marley concluded that the
only way to make some real money from
music was to start his own record
company and control the entire
production process from start to finish
this however also required a large sum
of cash to get going something which
Marley obviously didn't have since it
spent most nights sleeping on a door he
didn't own in 1965 Bob's mother sent
word for America asking him to join her
in Delaware Bob would later know that
their offer was extremely tempting but
he just met a girl called Rita Anderson
and the two had fallen in love so he
formulated a plan on February 10 1966
Bob and Rita got married afterwards Bob
left for America hoping to save enough
money to return to Jamaica and start a
record company Marley was answered being
just another Cog in the machine tell me
about it feeling that everything was and
I quote too fast too noisy too rush rush
even so he proved to be a hard worker
for example he started out as a lab
assistant at Dupont chemical and then he
worked on the assembly line of a
Chrysler Factory he also had a night
shift at warehouse and occasionally
picked up part-time shifts as a
dishwasher and parking lot attendant
however it wasn't all smooth sailing
because Marley frequently got into
conflicts and arguments with his mother
over religion a devout Christian woman
sadella wasn't happy that Osama become a
follower of the Rastafarian movement
which also persuaded Mali throughout his
signature dreadlocks meanwhile in
Jamaica the Whalers have continued to
create music substituting Mali with one
of Rita's cousins while Rita herself
will perform as part of a female Trio
called the i3s during this time the
Whalers also released an album called
The Wailing Wailers admittedly this is
just a compilation of earlier stuff
they've done but still they had an album
at the time scar had begun to declining
popularity in favor of the more relaxed
and deliberate rhythms of Rocksteady and
reggae Dodd kept stiffing the Whalers on
payment so the group left him a start
their own label in 1967. wailing Soul
record I'm gonna I'm gonna look it I'm
gonna bet I'm gonna BET right now that's
not going anymore but even though the
band who I make records They Knew diddly
Squat and how to sell them their record
label clothes by the end of the year
because of course it's not like they had
Bob Marley or anything working with them
fortunately for them all the offers
appeared the aforementioned producer
Leslie Kong approached the Whalers
wanting to record a new album using that
up-and-coming reggae style and it is
it's really good I do like reggae you
know contrary to what you see right here
at this like you know this Alabaster
complexion I do love me some Reggae it's
real good like sometimes on evenings put
some smooth Reggae on you grab a beer
you open the windows get the breeze
going through can't beat it
[Music]
the end result was the best of the
Whalers which oddly enough was not a
compilation album despite the name
apparently naming songs and albums was
not the Forte of the Whalers at that
time but then Kong dropped dead of a
sudden heart attack oh I did read ahead
but that still got me so the way it was
once again looking for a new producer in
1970 they embarked on a two-year working
relationship with Lee Scratch Perry who
produced two albums for the band soul
rebels and soul Revolution part two that
okay Soul Revolution there's no soul
Revolution part one but it was someone
else who For Better or Worse to play a
vital role in the introduction of the
Whalers to the rest of the world
Americans singer-songwriter Johnny Nash
not to be confused with Johnny Cash I
know my accent is a bit confusing and I
speak too quickly let me reiterate
Johnny Nash
[Music]
foreign
by the early 1970s the music coming out
of Jamaica had made its way Stateside an
American artists had started coming to
the Caribbean island looking for new
sounds and collaborators and one of them
was the aforementioned Johnny Nash a
houston-born singer who'd been active
since the mid 50s and Nash and his
manager won Danny Sims
um heard Marley playing approached him
with a deal basically Nash wanted to
help him get that reggae sound just
right in an exchange he promised new
opportunities on the international stage
a pretty sweet deal
well there was a caveat as there always
is Somali agreed and signed with Nash
and sims's record label Judd records his
first gig was in Sweden where he's
supposed to help Nash score the
soundtrack to a movie and that the
latter was starring in internationally
it was released as love is not a game
although none of Bob Marley's music made
it into the Final Cut still Sweden
pretty cool right bit of Sweden Bob
Marley you know I'll be mad free trip to
Sweden from Sweden Marley popped over to
London where he worked with Nash and his
band on their new album Danny Sims who
at this point was basically acting as
Miley's manager sent for the other
Whalers he wanted them on Johnny's album
but lure them to London with a promise
of a national tour was it turned out the
tour mainly consisted of us secondary
school and the occasional Club throwing
book of measure hey that means no some
some pretty Skokie out there heard Bob
Marley before he was famous and yeah
that's pretty cool that's pretty cool
right I'm only recorded a solo single
during this time titled Reggae on
Broadway but it flops harder than a
mattress being Sparta kicked into a pool
full of mercury and then one morning the
Whalers woke up in their cold and crappy
apartment in Bayswater to discover that
Nash and Sims had left England without
telling them trading the overcast Skies
of London the sunny skyline of Miami I
hope this gets good for Mali since I I'm
starting to feel bad I know that he's
was famous and Rich and successful but
I'm starting to feel bad for the dude
penniless and despondent Marley at least
discovered that he was famous at least
in London and was well known amongst the
music scene there due to the fact Dodd
had licensed several of their songs to
another label called Island records of
course Marley and the other band members
weren't paid for this and instead were
paid in exposure yeah they even got Bob
Marley with that
actually it turned out most places
didn't accept exposure so the Whalers
found themselves stranded in London and
in desperate need of cash using their
connections they eventually secured a
face-to-face with Chris Blackwell the
founder of Island Records Blackwell was
convinced that a Jamaican act could make
it big in London with the right guidance
and he thought that maybe the Whalers
could be the ACT specifically though we
thought that Bob Marley could be that as
far as Blackwell was concerned the rest
of the band didn't matter Bob Marley was
the star with that in mind Blackwell
agreed to loan them in advance they
could fly home and record a new album
I've got about give big props to Bob
Marley here that's a power move that
isn't it it's like we've been making
music in London for the past like year
or so but we need to be in Jamaica we
can't create that reggae sound without
being on the island of Jamaica now what
a hustle you go Bob you go back in
warmer and more familiar surroundings
the Whalers got right to work and after
a few weeks the album was done Marley
flew back to London with the Masters
under his supervision Blackwell works
with his own magic overdoing the tracks
to combine the smooth reggae sound with
the rock vibe that played well
commercially in London time he even got
Fame session musician Wayne Perkins
played lead guitar on a few tracks to
make them more rock and roll the end
result was capture Fire released in 1973
and nowadays considered one of the
greatest reggae albums ever made didn't
exactly sell like gangbusters but it did
do well enough for the way let's go on a
tour of the UK and the US during the
American tour the Whalers briefly opened
for Sly in the Family Stone we got fired
because the crowd liked them too much
and Sly didn't want to be and I quote a
warm-up act Keen to capitalize on their
Newfound success the group quickly got
to work on another album which released
later that same year titled burning it
was another hit with the critics and
included one of Bob Marley's defining
songs I Shot the Sheriff which was later
covered by Eric Clapton you know so
that's not like Eric stealing a black
person's music and making his own
you seemed that Molly had finally
arrived after the highs come the lows
unfortunately Blackwell's tendency to
focus on Mali didn't sit well with the
other two Founders Peter Tosh and Bonnie
Whaler who also weren't fans of doing
International shows on a late awesome
evening in the tour of England in 1973
tension between Tosh and Marley reached
a boiling point the two into a bitter
shouting match and they unofficially
disbanded at that moment the Whalers
were no more at least not as we knew
them Bob like to his credit did manage
to find a completely new lineup which
include his wife and the i3s and got
back to doing what he did best making
sweet sweet music the label also started
promoting the band as Bob Marley and the
Wailers just in case it wasn't clear who
the star was now normally losing the
entire lineup for a band would spell
Doom for that success but Miley star was
already shining too bright to be dimmed
by something as simple as every member
of the band leaving at once in 1974 in
October Bob Marley and the Whalers
released their seventh album nutty dread
it was once again popular critics and
sold the best out of all their albums so
far especially in the UK more
importantly though it included mali's
greatest hit No Woman No Cry a year
later that put out a live album that
also performed incredibly well in the
charts and more importantly include a
live version of No Woman No Cry that
went on to become the definitive version
of that song In 1976 Bob Marley released
his eighth album Rastaman vibrations
which went on to become his breakout hit
in the US and his first one to enter the
Billboard Top 10. by that point Bob
Marley had officially arrived as it were
and his albums were selling well and
concert demands were an all-time high
the Rolling Stone magazine just
proclaimed the Whalers the band of the
year nobody could deny that Bob Marley
was the most popular reggae artist in
the world or even that was the most
beloved figure in all of Jamaica at that
time when Jamaican Prime Minister
Michael Manley wanted for a concert to
ease the rising political tensions
Marley seemed like the obvious choice
for a headliner the concert was known
simply as Smile Jamaica and it came at a
time when the two main political
factions in the country the Social
Democratic People's National Party or
PNP and the conservative Jamaican labor
party or jlp were engaged in a conflict
that was starting to turn violent many
felt the country was a powder keg
waiting to explode there was a lot of
pressure for the concert to go smoothly
up until this point Marley had always
remained fairly apolitical saying and I
quote Rasta no go left no go right
raster go straight ahead yes can you
tell acting classes in college however
since the Jamaican Ministry of culture
was sponsoring the event a lot of people
saw it as a tacit endorsement of the
ruling political party the PNP on behalf
of Bob Marley and to make matters worse
the Prime Minister pulled off a real
sneaky move by calling for a snap
election on December 15 1976 10 days
after the show effectively turning Smile
Jamaica into a benefit concert for the
party Marley was reportedly furious with
manly as he was promised that it would
be and I quote just music no politics
but you know the Golden Rule The Show
Must Go On plus Bob didn't want to hurt
the people of Jamaica over the devious
actions of a few politicians who were
looking to use him to score some extra
points in the polls however by agreeing
to go through the concert Marley
unwittingly put himself into the
crosshairs of some dangerous people who
really really didn't want him to take
the stage it was December 3rd just two
days before the concert when Marley and
the Whalers would be rehearsing at his
home on 56 Hope Road they were in the
kitchen taking a well-earned break when
two white dachshunds filled with six or
seven gunmen reports aren't really clear
and pulled up outside his driveway and
made their way towards the house they
surround the building and opened fire
with automatic Weaponry fortunately even
though some of them were armed with
automatic rifles they displayed a let's
say Storm Trooper level of accuracy that
miraculously resulted in Zero fatalities
Marley's wife Rita was actually shot in
the head while trying to exit the house
and even though the bullet graced her
head and she was knocked out she
recovered with no real injury a family
friend named Louis Griffith took one to
the gut and Marley himself caught a
bullet that scratched his chest before
embedding itself in his arm chest into
the arm however it was Marley's manager
Don Taylor who got it worse and he was
shot five times he was rushed to the
hospital and despite being shot remember
5 different times he survived the ordeal
without any Serious injury but worst of
all was Marley's manager Don Taylor who
shot five times but after being rushed
to hospital for emergency surgery he too
recorded the ordeal with no lasting
injuries it's never been definitively
established he was behind the hit most
assume it was the jlp because
come on
pretty obvious right however no arrests
were made in the case and despite his
injury Marley lets us go through the
concept as he got on stage he sort of
exhilarated massive crowd of both PMP
and jlp supporters Marley said he would
sing one song because he couldn't strum
his guitar you know due to bullet wounds
he would go on to play for 90 straight
minutes turning the concert into the
symbol of peace and unity he'd always
been intended to be
following the concert Marley went to
recuperate in the Bahamas for a month
well afterwards decided not to return to
Jamaica but instead to travel to England
in a and I quote self-imposed Exile an
ordinarily I'd be annoyed at someone
like you know using England as like the
punchline of a joke but given what
England looks like 90 of the time like
all gray dreary and wet as you can
probably tell from my head I'm literally
recording this after getting in from my
morning jog during which just the skies
opened
I'll let Marley off for this one so
during that time he's been about two
years recording two new albums Exodus
and Kaya both were well received
especially Exodus which many consider
Marley's finest and best studio album
and contains the eponymous hit single as
well as Classics as a German one love
and three little birds and I would be
remiss if I did not say right now my
father's favorite Bob Marley joke how
does Bob Marley like his donuts with
German
look forward to jokes like that for many
more videos to come when it came time
for Marley to make his return to Jamaica
he did it for another show and tell us
to quell the political Civil War that
was still brewing in the country this
was the one love peace concert held on
April 22nd 1978 and it left behind a
powerful long-lasting image when Mali
invited on stage the two political
leaders Michael Manley who we've already
mentioned and Edward Sega and they all
held up their hands together in a show
of peace and unity it didn't last or
really work political violence in
Jamaica continue but hey it was worth a
shot unfortunately just as mali's
International career was really taking
off he was hit by serious health
problems while on the European tour of
Exodus Bob hurt his right foot during a
football game in Paris and since the
article doesn't clarify whether this was
football or I'd understand it as a
British person or football as an
American would understand it I'm gonna
have to just assume it was soccer for
you Americans because like that seems
more likely a more likely way to hurt
you thought like you know if you're just
like absolutely try to spoon the ball
all and kicks it wrong maybe that's what
we're on otherwise you know I stand
corrected if it was American Football
maybe the editor can put a little fact
bar into something to clarify that one
for me anyway
um like during this game in Paris he
went to the Doctor Who removed a jagged
piece of nail bandaged the wound and
asked Marley to stay off his feet it's
been Bob Marley that was out of the
question since he didn't want to stop
the tour and he certainly didn't want to
not go on stage and play his song so he
quite simply just played through the
pain often finishing concerts with his
right boot filled completely with blood
which you then have to drain after every
concert by June 1978 the European leg of
the tour had ended and bobber traveled
to Delaware to spend some time with his
mum and get ready for his U.S shows
however his toe was still not healed in
fact it got worse the point where he
could barely walk anymore he went to a
foot specialist who took a biopsy in
return with a dreaded diagnosis cancer
it was a very aggressive form of
melanoma that was often fatal but could
be treated if caught early on contrary
to a popular urban legend the football
injury didn't cause Miley's death the
council is already present when the
injury took place after seeking a second
opinion Mali was left with two options
the best was to amputate the cell this
is what his record label wanted since
had a short recovery time and thus meant
that Marley could get back to you know
being on tour and making the money never
change record industry but Marley didn't
want to lose his toe so he went against
his doctor's advice and just removed the
nail and adjacent flash while trying to
cleanse the wound as much as possible
how is that how is that what you choose
like I've seen Game of Thrones I've seen
the bit with Ramsay Bolton
and if you haven't seen the bit like
don't Google it because it's not very
nice but I do at that point if I was
having to scrape my wound that was close
to my bone of like no gangrenous
infected flesh I just cut I just cut it
off well you know Bob Marley's built
different apparently at first it looked
like it worked and two months after the
procedure Bob Marley was given a clean
bill of health and he was playing
football again
why why would you do that why and you
went into the studio and recorded two
more albums survival which was
absolutely named and Uprising in 1980
while on the uprising tour in New York
Marley collapsed while jogging he was
taken to the hospital was basically
handed a death sentence the cancer is
spread throughout his body including his
brain despite the devastating news Mali
still wanted to perform and he played
one final concert in Pittsburgh in
September 1980. after that his health
was really too frail to continue to do
pretty much anything when Marley came to
the realization that he was dying and
there wasn't really anything he could do
about it he wanted to be flown home to
Jamaica but his condition got worse
during the flight and that's making an
emergency stop in Florida Bob Marley
died in Miami on May 11 1981 age 36
receiving a state funeral in Jamaica 10
days later the impact here on music
became evident just a few years later
when his greatest hits album was
released it's still to this day the
best-selling reggae album of all time
and one of the best-selling albums
overall is titled quite fittingly Legend
and we got there in the end didn't we
folks and if anyone wondering who the
hell are you I'm Carl Smallwood and I
used to write for the sister site to
biographics top tens many many years ago
and they asked me to step in as interim
host if you don't like it let us know in
the comments and that they'll replace me
but if you did enjoy the video let us
know in the comments below and uh thank
you for watching and have the day you
deserve
I'll be correctly it's like it's
rastafar they they worship the jar Rasta
Therian
religion
God question mark oh it's a picture of
Bob Marley oh no because that's an
article about rastafarianism oh vagina
they do worship
them just worship Bob Marley that would
make sense well come on